welcome back everybody to led live
how does culture influence our
interpretation of the bible
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness hey everybody
welcome back to our show
led live where we use the light of
christ to expose some darkness but
you know today we're going to talk about
a topic of biblical culture
before we do that though we want to give
a shout out to our patreon donors
you guys are awesome thank you so much
for your donations to our ministry that
allow us to even put this kind of
content out for free
and you know we listen to you guys a lot
too if you have any suggestions
topics that you want us to cover we do
cover topics that you guys suggest from
time to time so
definitely write those questions or
those suggestions
in the comments section and we would
love to produce some shows for you guys
there's an another way to watch our
material is by getting our dvds we
actually sell a physical dvds you can
look it up on our shop or if you don't
have dvd players
you can go on our email and buy a
digital downloads
and we also have another way that you
can help support our work
tell them about this michelle if you can
see here
it's another way to wear your witness
through stickers you can place this on
your water bottle on your laptop
on your journal wherever you want we've
got some cool designs check them out
littlelightstudios.tv
we have a spanish channel that um
really where we're really excited about
inviting on another team member for
little light studios to produce
all of this material that you see with
us in spanish
and we will have that available in the
near future
we also have an international channel
where other people have actually
given us versions of our videos with
their languages
on them so we want to to post those in
one location so
check that out we have a little light
studios international channel and we'll
put a couple of those links in the
description below
right now we're working with an
indonesian speaker and we're working
with a
portuguese speaker but if you are anyone
else who speaks any other language
please reach out to us we need your help
in making this
channel as functional and uh to reach as
many people as possible
probably by the time this video comes
out subtitles have gone away on youtube
that's no longer an option so this is a
really great way to
offer people our videos in your language
there was one more thing i was going to
bring up to
amazon smile that's what it was amazon
smile
amazon smile and giving assistant you
can help support our ministry
using either those two you shop they'll
give us money
that's the way it works it's a great
it's a great day yeah
yeah great what do you call it great
deal yeah
everybody wins everybody wins welcome
back michael
to our show it's been a joy to have you
on our show and talk about some of these
topics and i'm looking forward to this
topic as well because i know
that um a lot of times we come at the
bible from
uh you know a perspective that we've
grown up in
a culture that we've grown up in and
sometimes other people don't share that
same thing so what do we do in that
situation
how do we navigate through that um i'm
kind of excited to hear what you have to
say
yeah well you know the bible was written
during a specific time
with specific viewpoints along a very
specifically
narrow area along the mediterranean sea
so life was pretty much the same for
everybody reading
not the entire time we had
higher class people traveling but for
the most part everybody had the same
life but
today there's there's people like oh
we're making money on um
social media we're you know doing nine
to five we have different
lifestyles and so that really changes
the perspective that we have like
one passage could mean this to one
person and this to another
mainly because this is how our life
is not saying that's wrong but it's just
not how the original readers would have
thought about it or the original
the people within the story themselves
would have
thought about it through the entire old
testament everybody was just
agricultural based that's that was their
life agriculture
you would work till the sabbath that was
a feast and then
you would go back to work until the next
feast
and the the men would be out hunting
or gathering doing essentially garden
work
in some cases uh the women would be
making
the stuff that we bring back and that
was a lot more difficult
uh because they had to make it by
scratch there's
no bread maker you have to make your own
stuff
and figure out a way to heat it up and
stuff so you would use
things like animal done and it's just
not at all what we're used to today
because
are you a farmer uh you know what i love
gardening actually i have totally
fallen in love with it but no not a
farmer in the center right i've never
grown anything more than
maybe a 50-foot yard you know
strip yeah so that's not the same thing
your
your livelihood isn't based on that food
anybody else
no nobody has lived that type of life
and so this agricultural theme
throughout the bible can get lost
i mean a lot of jesus parables were
based but a lot of the people he was
talking to
some of them were agriculturally based
and the ones who didn't understand were
the
the upper class the ones who were
traveling the the people who were
like hey who is this guy what is he
saying
and you could tell like i mean even his
disciples didn't
know what he was saying half the time
until he clarified it
you know i wonder what jesus would have
said today if he'd even like so you're
playing on facebook
and uh you know i don't know it's just
like
probably would have used the tools that
we're familiar with today
right you know i know jesus would have
used an apple computer not a pc
that's funny but yeah things the
parables would be
massively different i think about um the
parable of talents
you know the master was going on a
journey gives them
the talents a lot of people use that how
do
people use that parable now a lot of the
time i
see it they're literally using it to
explain
talents that we understand it as
you know like i have a gift for
blank that that's that's how a lot of
people use it you've noticed that yeah
but but that's not what a talent is it's
not a talent
is about 1.4 million dollars
so i don't know if you're going to get
into this but it really brings up the
question of
when you're in when you're reading a
passage and trying to figure out what it
means
how do you do that the way i understand
it i have understood it
so far is you need to read it and it's
historical
context using you know historical
grammatical method in order to
understand what did that text mean
at that time to the people it was
written to
what were they thinking yeah there's an
application
beyond that which is what you start to
get into
what like other people are doing and
it's the
the homiletical application which can be
very broad but you also have to be
careful with because it it can
lend itself to twisting the bible in
ways that it's not meant to be twisted
so
i mean like uh telling us that we're all
supposed to be rich
oh
some of the early church fathers like
origen he would take the parable of the
good samaritan
and then it would assign symbolism
to all the characters yeah
it sounds good but it's
not necessarily true and
and whereas it sounds good you can make
the application
the danger is well if he can come along
and assign
those symbols why can't anybody yeah do
the same thing
and then you have then it's open season
on whatever it means
right so there has to be rules of
interpretation
in order to bring out the meaning that's
i do think it is neat though that god
wrote the bible in such a way
that it could make sense to an
agriculturally minded
individual and then someone in 2020 that
sits in front of a computer all day long
i go that makes sense to me so you know
i think that there is this
really interesting application where you
can kind of
see it in two different lights but it
can have sort of the same
impact on you but how much more impact
could it have if you actually understood
what they themselves were
were dealing with which is why like they
made
the entire time with just a huge
like agricultural boom
up until between the testaments
then there was a um sort of industrial
revolution
that brought in alexander the gray and
he
tried to do what he could to the
to the hebrews and they were like no
we're not having this
they led a revolt and that worked
up until 37 years later
and then here comes uh pilot and
the other roman governors and everything
puts herod in charge and
yay it is like everything was
agricultural
agricultural and then they were able to
like push it
the reason why jews weren't so much
in problematic standing with
the romans were because their beliefs
were tradition
and and rome like loved tradition so
like
yeah okay you don't as long as you don't
hate on caesar
we're not going to bother you for not
calling him your god
but they were still being agricultural
they were still doing this and then
there were
you know rabbis traveling and whatnot
and these are the people
relating uh to the others and when jesus
comes on the scene they're
they're still upset about that
revolution that happened
a little over like 60 or so
years prior here he is claiming to be a
messiah who is not like
judas maccabias who led the revolt the
one who was going to overturn government
they wanted something like that so they
were upset
and their agricultural life kept being
derailed they
viewed everything on this thing their
days of the month
uh their their months were based on
seasons and not
you know we have like oh september is
this this this this
this but you hear that in the
terminology of the bible too from one
moon
new moon to another yeah yeah from one
new moon to the other
from one sabbath day to the next sabbath
day
but um their months would change
depending like oh the seasons are
shifting a bit we're adding another
month so that these
months can still fit within the season
rather than today like oh
september's a little bit warmer this
year well
no that's not that's not how they work
they were like oh it's getting warmer
that means it's
not uh this day it's actually this month
we gotta add another month to fit that
um
because it was how they were constantly
adjusting
things they were constantly adjusting
their uh
their month they weren't changing the
amount of days or anything they were
just adding
a month or not depending so that they
can
uh keep on their regular
track so that nothing got misconstrued
or
confused in their livelihood oh uh
the importance of olives oh my goodness
um olives was the oil they would use
that for oil
for cooking would you say that was like
their currency
no their currency was um mainly
grapes and livestock okay
livestock because they start they
started
the idea of animal husbandry which is to
use
animals to make more for food
but only for the months
in which you may or may not have a
famine
it wasn't intentional like oh we're
going to eat meat all the time we
they only ever ate meat during festivals
vegetarianism was pretty much
everybody's life
unless there was a famine or it was a
festival because they needed to get rid
of the excess somehow
but olives were used for the oil for
anointing for cooking
and grapes used for raisins and wine
they
loved wine this is this was their
currency
and today like we wouldn't even have
that
you can see it in the scripture that
these things were important
but when you don't like when you only
think about it in this today's aspect we
we don't give goats away maybe farmers
do
nobody here's a farmer i lived with i
lived amongst farmers but i never saw it
you know again we live in this
revolutionized
age of technology and stuff nothing
that they had is pertaining to most of
what we have however
if you understand this you can connect
it
like i can connect the idea of paying
for
something with something people find
valuable
but not by not goats and wine the bible
is full of principles that's what it's
so awesome about it that it can be
applied to pretty much anything
and you kind of see the cultural
differences even within the bible as you
were saying
look at the old testament you're talking
about the wealth of abraham yeah that
was a livestock
when you go into the new testament job
right exactly
and when you go into the new testament
you hear of a rich person it's like the
tax collectors it was coin wealth
not necessarily how much cattle that
they had so even within the bible there
are different cultural aspects
yeah because the romans you know we're
taking over we're doing what we do
and so we're going to hire these jews to
tax other jews and then we're gonna get
somebody who seems jewish but
isn't jewish to rule over them um
just to you know to to appease them and
they were really afraid
because you know their their freedom at
the time
was like very very fragile if there was
anybody who claimed to be king
they were they're gonna get taken down
and so jesus saying you know claiming to
be the messiah in any way shape or form
doing miracles they were like we need
him to either take over the government
which he's not doing
or take him down because he's just gonna
ruin our
our freedom our life and so
what are we supposed to do you know what
and how are we supposed to look at that
in today's aspect we don't have that
problem at least
not in america and that's all i can
speak on
we don't have this uh what is it
wavering freedom based on
a king or not if i claim jesus christ is
the lord
i'm not gonna get you know hunted down
by the president
not yet you just wait
yeah i'm ready for that so so let me
understand this
a little bit oh oh this is the the way
of life that jesus is coming
into and you know he comes into a time
when i think that culturally they were
actually
as a unified body looking for some
different type of savior
yeah and jesus comes and steps on the
scene and they're like no no no
that's not really what we want we want
this and they've
been centuries of telling each other
what the messiah is going to look like
and act like and be like and then he
steps on the scene and he's nothing like
what they were
anticipating so to say um you know
talk a little bit about that like how
did the how did the culture of the day
feed into their belief of who jesus was
so
again we had the the revolution and so
they wanted somebody who was going to
overthrow
government a lot of the prophecies
from that mindset looks like he is
supposed to be
a political king not just a you know a
temporary not temporary crisis not
temporary he lives
forever and ever but you know not
somebody who's going to be on the earth
temporarily
and as long as he's on here for three
years you know
on the scene for three years um he's
going to set up his kingdom
he's going to set up his kingdom for
three years and then we got to do the
rest of the work
but that's not what they wanted that was
antithetical to what they were hoping
for because they only had 37 years of
freedom
and then here comes another group and
they just kept and prior
they get they just kept getting you know
harmed so when we get
to that point their their cultural
mindset
is like this is harmful to
all of us all of the people living in
rome
this guy continuing because we had this
amazing family 60-something years
prior to this kid's birth
rule give us autonomy and and be
israel the way that you know we were
promised
and this kept happening they were kind
of just
broken they couldn't figure it out so
they just
tried to go on with regular life with
their
using their own style of money between
each other but then using the roman
style just to live which is why
what do we do with this money give to
caesar's what diseases give to god what
is god
how are we this is this was their
argument their problem
with all that they just wanted to be
left alone and i feel like
right now in the world a lot of people
just want to be left alone
but not in this way that if somebody
offered somebody hope
not necessarily all the time in jesus
which is sad
so people are going to take it people
are going to take the
opportunity of hope and we see that we
see that if
something happens with what's going on
in this world some we're gonna jump
to to take that hope to to no longer be
in this predicament we're in
but that that wasn't offer that didn't
look like it was the hope that was
offered by god in the beginning
to the people who had been enslaved and
set free and then enslaved again
over and over again and
still going on i i've
it's it's sad when you think about um
i'm thinking about the holocaust you
know the
the the jewish people had to go through
that right
and and some of them kept on to their
faith
some of them didn't and the ones who
didn't
they were they were broken they were
beaten they were like how could god
do this to us and so there can't be a
god similar to
my testimony but you know
within the context of the bible
it just looks like the story continues
and it's a sad way to think about it
the story continues because the hope
is is hidden
and nobody wants to open their eyes not
now not then
so in that way culture is the same but
how we lived our lives are
vastly vastly different
so how do you think um today you know
we kind of have an understanding jesus
is coming again
we're anticipating jesus coming again
how can
the culture or the current situation of
what we are
hopeful for or whatever be
um you know different between
us what we're all anticipating i mean
all christendom kind of has a bit of a
different
angle of what they're hopeful for
how do we rectify this how do we rectify
the differences between denominations
let's do your questions i just mean like
you know
thousands and thousands of denominations
yeah in culture
like you know like where where like
i guess what i'm trying to draw out is
like you know if the jews
really would have been going back and
studying the prophecies and seeing
what the suffering savior was going to
be like it would have
hopefully saved them from missing that
you know what i mean
and i think that if we stand more on the
bible and
understanding of of christ's second
coming
how he's coming what he's asking for us
to be prepared for him
to come you know i think is different
than some
that's an interesting point do you think
their interpretation of the bible
came from their environment that culture
so the jews previous to the roman rule
do you think they had that same
understanding of what the messiah would
look like
i think prior to the
maccabean revolt and specifically the
alexandrian conquest i think that
those people um would have been like
okay
if they saw this version the jesus that
we know the savior we know
if they saw that one it's more likely
they'd be like oh
yeah that definitely fits all the
prophecies we have
but you know again culture shades the
way we look at things and so
after this whole conquest and then the
revolt
it's it's not because their idea of a
savior has now
changed from so desperate for that
eternity to
this guy riding on horseback and so the
same water
are we in danger of that right today
exact thing today
i think in some cases we are because
culture has
advanced so much that
the differences of reading the scripture
the way it was and reading the scripture
the way we
see it everybody has these different
ideas of
how this is going to go down i mean
you've had the episode on the rapture
right like nowhere in the bible is that
actually stated but matthew 24 says
something that looks like it
um same with luke and
it looks like it but it's not ever
stated that's what it is
and when it says one will be here and
one will be left
it's actually the one who is the
christian is the one who's left
you've known the story of how the the
rapture
idea came right the pre-trib rapture at
least came
not necessarily um
it goes something along the lines of
there's a church in england
and one of their congregant members
a girl has a dream about this
and tells the pastor and he's like well
this makes sense with our culture and
what what's written in the bible but it
wasn't
you talking about margaret mcdonald yes
it's one it's it's a very popular story
it's a very
explanatory of why we have the concept
of rapture
pre-trib at least and then that's what
eventually made its way into like darby
and scofield's translations
exactly what happened well not their
translation but their study bibles
sure the translations were the same just
the identity of a change and so
these constant changes in our society
gives a different
uh color to text
and so that's the that is a danger but
if we can
remember where we came from and i mean i
like to study a bit of church history to
see what they thought
prior to any of what we did and yeah you
brought up origen
he had you know slightly different
things that happened you know
centuries later but nonetheless earlier
than us
i'm reflecting on this thinking that
i think jews as a people valued literacy
and specifically biblical
literacy it's what they had and told
about their history it told about the
coming messiah it's how they understood
who they were
[Music]
and even with a high amount
of biblical literacy you see the
influence
of maybe the political situation or the
times or the culture
skewing their viewpoints and giving them
maybe an improper understanding of of
what was to come
and i think the maybe
bigger danger is now biblical literacy
is probably
low comparatively oh absolutely
and we're still trying to make sense of
the world
and if biblical literacy is low even
among christians
how can we understand the times that we
live in
or whatever it's going to be
times and seasons but you cannot tell
the times of the age
i think that's a real danger of
where we're at and we have culture is
always an influence
um probably the greeks
i mean huge example right because even
you know it's said that you know rome
conquered uh the world
basically from without but greek you
know conquered the world from within
and so you know they had an influence on
the romans
and then it continued to influence
things like judaism and you know
christianity
and it's still influencing our our
society today greek
a lot of different styles of thought
culture yeah
yeah so i'm you know while
culture has always been a big influence
and now we're just
faced with all this pop culture you know
which is
constantly evolving constantly changing
it's like you're on
from one thing to the next even the news
it's like last week's news was old news
let's move on to the next thing
yeah and trying to make sense of the
world around you
if you don't have a foundation over here
and then the other thing that you're
interested in is constantly changing i
don't know how you would understand
anything
i mean it's no wonder it's like the
world is in chaos
because that's the way we live
we live in chaos essentially literal i
mean
you know intellectual and physical chaos
that's all we live in yeah because we
just get this same thing over as you
just said it's just
new thing next next next next and and
for biblical uh bible literacy
we we just listen to the guy in the
pulpit and that's that's it
so my question then is how do we
navigate
through this knowing this able to look
it back in history and see how
culturally you know we missed the boat
with jesus the first time
and we're going to miss a lot of things
the second time
there's a lot of people that you know
maybe are not
understanding that they're being swayed
in one direction or another
how do we navigate through this what
what what advice would you guys have
so i guess one of my answers would be
romans 13 11 it says
and do this knowing the time that now is
high time to wake out of sleep for now
our salvation is nearer than we first
believed so we need to wake up
and part of waking up is
immersing ourselves back in god's word
if you look again back at
the jews as a people and even you know
further back before they were known as
jews
it was the people who followed god who
loved god who had a relationship with
god
who who communicated with him who
obeyed his voice did what he said all of
that led up to
um them having direction and
purpose and clarity in their life
and through that they were able you know
god showed many people
even before there were uh you know
written scriptures
this is what's going to happen this is
what's to be prepared for you know moses
was shown a
you know basically this is how it's all
going down
um as you know abraham
seemed forward to what was gonna happen
at the cross you know
god has as ways of straightening us
out now we have uh his word we have
really no excuse
you know he's given us his word we can
look at that we know what's coming
what's
what's to happen we have all this wisdom
for our lives
that's what we need to ground ourselves
in and and have a foundation
it's like you know the bible talks about
that parable it's like the wise man
built his house upon a rock
you know don't build your foundation on
culture the sands of this life
where everything's gonna get washed away
it has to be built on the rock
jesus that's why i point to uh first
peter 30 15 a lot to always
be ready and willing to give a defense
because
if you're not then you can be swayed by
anything it's like if you stand for
nothing you'll fall for anything
and it's this it's dangerous so always
be ready
you need to be in your word nobody knows
the day or hour he's coming and if we
all miss it
well it ain't gonna be some people are
left behind and some people
are here it's gonna be we're all tossed
anybody who's
confused enough to not know what's going
on
i think if you're really diligently
studying the bible
you have the holy spirit that will
direct you in all paths of truth right
i mean you think of the story of simon
when when he held the baby jesus for the
first time
and he knew that was jesus like he knew
that was the savior like i always i was
always heard that story and i was just
was like wow
like like how did you know i mean they
weren't running around broadcasting that
this was the son of god
they see babies all the time right the
holy spirit
directed his mind and said this is the
way this is the truth right here
this is the path and i think that the
more that we
engage with with with jesus in his word
the more that we understand how he's
worked in the past
how he's working with us today then we
don't
get swayed by all the cultural ideas of
what's actually happening and and people
just kind of like you know throw it oh i
think it's just like this or i think
it's just like this i mean it has to be
grounded in the word
of god you mentioned in the beginning
how
the bible is uh relevant to people
before
and 2020. i guess that's yeah like
that's what i want to ground myself in
on something that does not change like
kids say on
on a rock like the bible it's still
relevant for us today and relevant for
us like
1000 years ago but with the culture
that we are in right now it may be not
relevant 20 years ahead or
for our parents it may not be relevant
too yeah
but here's what's neat like okay you
know the bible in the old
context is really an agricultural
understanding right
but you know what we actually are all
farmers
we all are do you know why because we're
planting seeds in the mine
and you should be farming people's
hearts right so
in a spiritual sense we can apply
these things to our understanding going
hey look like
like oh okay cultivating the soil well
we need to talk about that in terms of
cultivating the heart
and those lessons in the dirt really are
lessons for us
in our spiritual walk and so uh you know
i think that you can kind of look back
in a historical context you can get an
understanding and then you can say how
is this applicable to my life
today how can i understand this
but it does help to know where they're
coming from for sure
and speaking to culture i mean even at
this table indonesia
american um italian saint lucian right
we have all these different cultures
but separate from that is the culture of
christ you know and a lot of times the
things that the principles and the
culture within the bible are in conflict
with our personal
cultures and it's good to have those
cultures to fall back on
to relate to people to have a better
understanding of life and all these kind
of things
but we need to remember that spiritual
things are spiritually discerned
so looking outside of who we are in our
cultures and trying to
not come with any bias when it comes to
reading god's word
and as you were saying asking the holy
spirit to definitely guide us
i think we'll definitely put some
safeguards up as we're trying to
interpret
god's word and not come with any of our
own biases okay
because the mention of this world
changes
you know i think we have to realize
christ is calling us to a different
culture
his culture his kingdom his ways because
everything on this earth
doesn't stand the test of time and
especially like when you go with
morals and ideals
you know we we live in such a shifting
society that was what was right 50 years
ago
is not right anymore yeah so
what's right today we have to question
looking at our own
recent history will that be right
tomorrow you know
with jesus it's not like that it's right
for all time it's right for all time
and that's why it can work for everybody
in every culture
because you can see the principles that
they're eternal
and that they work so and i also love it
that each
generation that goes by you know like
paul spoke about
you know now is the time now is high
time right
that our salvation is nearer right how
many thousands of years ago did he write
that
but in in a sense we are all like
given that same chunk of time so to say
whether he comes in our lifetime or he
comes in someone else's lifetime we
still are granted the same amount of
time
as paul did and every day that you pass
by
that salvation to you in a sense is
nearer
obviously and you know i think that's
what's
the phenomenon about the bible i think
it is relevant and urgent
for those people back then as it is for
us today
okay so as we as we learn that so we can
uh what we can take home is that even
though the culture in the bible time
and today is completely different
yet the bible can be relevant to us
today as
it was to the people thousands of years
ago
so we can safely say that the bible the
word of god
is the truth that we should stand upon
today amen thank you guys for
tuning in for another show of led live
and as you hear us say over and over and
over again we just hope
that you guys are getting inspired to
jump in the word of god to really know
what you believe
and and you know don't don't get
so distracted with the cultural ideas
that are out there go
straight to the source and that source
of truth
is found in the word of god and build
your foundation
upon that because as you can see
culture can shift culture can change and
it can really
uh throw you off course and so we just
want to
encourage you and and and hopefully you
get inspired
to to really just pick up your bible and
get to know the god of the bible spend
time with him
in his word and the holy spirit will
direct your paths
and i'm curious like anyone who's
watching if you wouldn't mind leaving in
the comment section below
where you're from where you're watching
this episode from it'll be really cool
to find out the different cultures that
watch led live
there you go there you go and it is neat
because we do hear from you guys from
time to time
all around the world hey we're in africa
right now it's in the middle of the
night we're watching your show
philippines
yeah you know so thank you guys from
wherever you're at
and we look forward to a day that we
actually get to meet you face to face
in the kingdom of heaven and we know
that day is approaching soon so hang on
tight
michael thank you for coming on our show
once again and
sharing some of the things that you're
learning in in seminary school
and what a blessing to have you thank
you so much thank you guys for watching
we'll see you next friday
[Music]
you